bienvenue à paroles de talent comme ici
c'est mélissa mollen dupuis cette
semaine j'ai reçu une question de raynal
qui me demandent comment fonctionne sur
les territoires des premières nations
les services qui ailleurs sont fournis
par les administrations municipales sur
une réserve à cause de la loi sur les
indiens
tout ce qui est des questions fédérales
provinciales et municipales sont pris en
charge par le conseil de bande
des fois il peut y avoir des empreintes
servait ça dépend des financements par
exemple pour la police ou du déneigement
s'il va avoir des ententes en des
municipalités et les réserves mais
l'aspect municipal c'est vraiment le
conseil demande qui en charge mais
savait pas dire que quand il ya réserve
il ya nécessairement besoin de services
municipaux
je pense particulièrement une communauté
l'accord la communauté de cacouna ya la
réserve qui s'appelle chrono 22 qui elle
0 habitat au mètre carré parce que c'est
s'est rendue incertaine au petit que la
réserve elle est vraiment dans une
maison qui s'en prend maintenant
d'artisanat et d'enseignement de la
culture des malécites de viger
mais ça veut pas dire qu'il n'ya pas de
mal et si tu sais ça veut seulement dire
qu'ils sont répartis un peu partout au
québec et aussi un peu plus dans les
maritimes
mais pour répondre au mans simplement
des questions rénale
c'est une question qui revient à conseil
devant alors tout ce qui est sur le
territoire provincial qui a été mis de
côté pour faire une réserve tombe sous
la couronne et donc pour la question
fédérale des indiens inscrit donc ce
sont le conseil de bande
j'espère avoir pu répondre à ta question
rénale et j'espère que vous allez
partager une vidéo vous avez vous envoyé
des questions
je souhaite une très belle semaine